the first thing you notice about michael
mann's heat is that it's all long lenses
in a wide screen twenty three by nine
format meant to allow for a broad scope
so that you can see more man crowds his
subjects into the frame as if you were
always watching them on a stakeout from
some hidden vantage on the building
opposite the telephoto lens is really
the perfect lens for this film it has
the effect of keeping everything at a
distance while at the same time
separating people from the background
while also at the same time turning the
background into an almost liquid plane
of lights evoke annette fantastical
romance that has always found in new are
and which michael man sees in the sprawl
of los angeles this is all to say that
the telephoto lens is both functional
and stylistic and heat to words that
could be used to describe the driving
ethos behind man's work of course style
is never something michael mann's been
accused of lacking in fact it's likely
accusations of empty stylistics from the
days of Miami Vice that made man insist
that he wasn't a genre film at all but a
drama drawn from the stories of a
real-life detective who served as a
consultant on the film and it's true the
procedural and mundane elements of
police and criminal activity are
painstakingly rendered in heat and
there's a pride in the fact that the
locations are real locations in LA this
was an actual cardboard community on
Terminal Island this train that the Niro
gets out of is the real blue line of the
Los Angeles MTA and his house is a real
house in Malibu by the sea but man can't
hide his knack for and devotion to style
the three locations I mentioned may be
real places but it's not an accident
that in the first a giant mound of
yellow sulfur gives the space a
dreamlike quality or that the train
platform feels both
and alienating and as for De Niro's home
what could call attention to itself more
than this blue suffuse box of loneliness
crib from Alex Colville's 1967 painting
Pacific in other words despite Michael
Mann's protestations that this is not a
genre piece heat is clearly drawing from
both crime and doir traditions what
makes the film brilliant is that it uses
its style and realism to comment on each
other and in doing so updates the genre
for a new age a lot of this is done
through sound in the film by the great
work in Chris Jenkins sound design and
Elliot Goldenthal score the interplay is
established right at the start as golden
Thals spacey highly stylized score fades
into the hyper real sounds of a hospital
and that exchange is in the soundtrack
to for the scene where Pacino chases
down to Nero on the highway man uses a
Joy Division song called new dawn fades
that has a driving rhythm that fits the
moment Turpin
but what I just played that's actually
not the song used in the movie man
commissioned a cover of new dawn fades
by the electronic artist Moby who super
adds to this functional moment a layer
of pure style listen to the difference
it makes
since its beginning there has been
attention in film noir between realism
and style its origins in black-and-white
and harsh chiaroscuro lighting attempted
to communicate a gritty realism but in
this lighting then in the implicitly
abstract nature of black and white it
created a style all its own its values
however were always traditional from the
start noir has investigated the way men
construct their identities from what
they do that reflected the broad scope
of men in the early 20th century not
just cops and robbers but the rise of
postmodern consumerist culture of new
ways to build identity that weren't from
one's career or one's relationships made
the crime films association with style
more problematic but also more necessary
man confronts this head-on with De Niro
and Pacino Scarah ters De Niro style has
slick suits his minimal empty house
reflect his lifestyle of extreme
professionalism matched in the actual
yuppie culture of the 80s when the film
was first conceived Pacino too is placed
in the actual home of postmodern
architect Tom main in Santa Monica man
knows that to communicate with
contemporary audiences to make a crime
nor that is fresh and looks forward
these stylistic choices have to be
present modern audiences firmly
entrenched in this culture register
style they speak themselves through
style and it's through this attention to
style that he can finally level a
critique on its own culture in the end
De Niro and Pacino ultimately reject
these new forms of identity construction
you can lounge around here on her sofa
in her ex-husband's dead tech post
modernistic bullshit house if you want
to and they fall back on traditional
methods Pacino looks to his work and De
Niro looks to relationships all I know
there's no point you're going anywhere
anymore it's gonna be wrong in this way
michael mann's attention to style and
score and soundtrack in lenses in
locations in wardrobe in lighting and is
attention to realism in all those same
categories serve to illustrate a new
social environment as well as its
drawbacks and that's what film noir was
always meant to do at its best show the
underside of culture and why it's a
necessary extension of the reverse in
fact it may be the case in our modern
culture that when the two sides are put
face to face they don't look all that
different
hey everybody thanks for watching heat
is one of the best crime thrillers of
all time no question about that I just
want to say that 2015 has been the best
year of my life but you guys have helped
me expand this channel to something that
I never could have imagined that of fact
that I get to do this full-time is just
beyond my wildest dreams I believe in
this channel so much and the work that's
happening here and I really believe that
to exist in 2016 and beyond it has to
innovate an experiment and do new things
and that is what I'm looking forward to
doing and looking forward to giving to
you there's a really special
relationship between the people who
watch this channel pledge to this
channel on my patreon page and me
because there's nothing in between us
and that's a model that I talked about
after every video but one that I really
really really really believe in because
this content is not diluted by any
corporation or any brand or anything
like that and that's I think really
special and I think a new model for the
way that content can be so I just want
to say thank you for 2015 you guys have
been awesome if you do want to pledge
you can click right there and go to my
patreon page I will see you guys next
Wednesday in 2016 and hopefully an
exciting year to come